قوامها حليب ونشاء وسكر في رمضان وفي
المناسبات السعيده اكلها يكسر تزين
بالقرفه والمكسرات وجوز الهند وبغير احساس
السعاده بعد تناولها لن تشعر
في اصل المهلبيه يقال انها سميت بهذا
الاسم نسبه الى شجره المحلب التي يستخدم
لبها لصنع هذا الطبق الحلو منها
وفي قصه اخرى يقال ان اصل التسميه مشتق من
استخدام الحليب فيها بكثره فهو مكونها
الاساسي
قصه ثالثه تقول ان الطبق سمي نسبه الى
يزيد بن المهلب بن ابي صفره الذي امر خدمه
بصنع طبق مميز من الحلوى يخلد اسمه في
التاريخ ولكن تبقى هذه القصه ضعيفه المصدر
وتعرف المهلبيه باسماء مختلفه في الدول
العربيه ففي مصر هي المهلبيه وفي سوريا
محلايه وفي ليبيا تعرف باسم محلبيه
سواء كنت تحبه مع قليلا من الارز او
السميد تبقى المهلبيه الطبق السهل سريع
التحضير على موائد رمضان